bei dem thema sind vor allem wir
verbraucher gefragt weniger fleisch
essen und ruhig auch mal nachverfolgen
wo das zeug herkommt und die politik
könnte zum beispiel mal aufhören
eu-subventionen nach fläche zu verteilen
fördermittel nicht mehr bestimmt pro
hektar sondern vielleicht mal weil sie
nicht pro glücklichen schwein
wir schalten mal leicht zur grünen woche
zu antonia von hausten sprecherin des
deutschen bauernverbandes von außen wann
geht der trend endlich zurück zum guten
alten klein bauernhof entschuldigen sie
hier welt gibt da sie doch jetzt auch
mal herzhaft lache
es gibt in deutschland noch genau zwei
kleine bauernhöfe den einen braucht rtl
für bauer sucht frau wo die inka bause
die immer verkuppelt diese grenzdebilen
fertig wenn du und der andere ist unser
foto motiv für fleischprodukte wie zum
beispiel die gute flöten walter rügen
wurst brüdern wurscht
na ja da sind ganze horden drin und köln
ja ja der welt mir vom bauernverband
fahren jetzt eine ganz neue strategie
mir stehen zur industriellen
landwirtschaft so schaut's aus
hier unser neues angebot für die ganze
familie ferien auf dem riesen bauernhof
zwei wochen voll funktion im schlimmsten
schweinchen aston niedersachsen
übernachten sie einmal ganz romantisch
in einer original schreine box schaut
mal die beiden ligen schon mal probe
weniger als ein quadratmeter passau
kuschelig ich muss auf die toilette ab
keiner so einfach laufen lassen das ist
der boden
ist ja furchtbar und dafür gibt es
einmal erfreuliche wilke andere höfe
horner ja kaum noch 90 prozent der
schweine in deutschland kämen aus mast
fabriken
darum ist deutsches schweinefleisch des
ja klar weil bei uns so am rumänen
schlachten und zerlegen für weniger als
einen euro pro tier da wissen was sie
gutmensch mir vom bauernverband haben
die schnauze voll von diesen ganzen
neuen bewussten kunden nicht wissen wo
der schweiz er kommt ja aber so ist wohl
her komme aus einem anderen schwein du
bist ja wir solche kunden neun jahren
sie würden rohes mett essen hält immer
auch wenn sie wissen dass da eventuell
er war alles schon alles gegessen
ja schon ein einziges net brötchen deckt
den tagesbedarf eines erwachsenen an med
das wissen viele gar nicht daher welche
ja das müssen sie sich das müssen sie
mal erleben ja ferien auf dem riesen
bauernhof ja sie und ihre frau
entspannen sich im gülle bad und die
kinder spüren zu lange auf dem bolzplatz
da kriegt jedes kind ab
bolzenschussgerät da kümmert die
kälbchen die party so ich muss jetzt
hier weiterarbeiten darf ich sie mal
ansprechen ja immer grüß gott hätten sie
vielleicht lust auf eine amüsante runde
köthen werfen
oh ja davon ist der küchenchef
ja der schwebe und für jeden treffer
gibt es einen 10 nackensteak bitte von
sun ich drücke ich ganz fest die daumen
klickt die skythen kurzem schule gibt es
morgen kurz räder
[Applaus]